le cuir est à venir max gallo le pire
est toujours sur le fier et sûr comme
vous êtes quelqu'un de cultivé
d'intelligent de briand bien sûr on va
vous faire l'interview nul lumière s'il
vous plaît on ne bouge pas au jingle
bravo je dois dire ah ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui se maîtrisent parfaitement
d'incroyable il n'a pas cillé
pendant leurs carcasses comme ça ils
mobile soit elle reste dans l'interview
nul il faut il maintenant l'interview
nul alors est ce que vous préférez c'est
on commence avec vous sur quoi c'est
toujours des choix c'est votre surnom
alors est ce que vous préférez quand on
vous appelle le malraux des campings ou
le michelez d'hypermarchés hausse et
équivalence peut-être le mal rôde et
camping préféré le malheureux des gens
bien dormir sous la tente
très bien lundi doit durer un truc
normalement alors il le diminuer est-ce
que vous préfériez votre père votre mère
la mère jusqu'à 14 ans le père après la
bonne réponse vous préférez hitler ou
staline est ce que je préfère mourir
dans une chambre à gaz ou dans un
chaudron
ouais c'est pas donc c'est une des
formes de mort je peux pas choisir entre
méforme de mort est-ce que vous
préféreriez on se concentre je me
concentre tout faire aurier est
réincarné en françois hollande ou en
jacques toubon aux jeux préférés en mode
la mort ouais il faut choisir faut
choisir françois hollande françois
hollande pourtant il n'est pas tendre
avec vous françois hollande il est pas
tendre avec moi mais je les ai vus
naître à la politique
ouais car le hasard fait les choses
quand j'ai été porte parole du
gouvernement il était mon directeur de
cabinet avaient donc c'est j'ai vu tout
petit en culottes courtes mais ils
visent des chaussures ou terrible il dit
qu' à l'époque vous combattiez médecin à
nice et que maintenant vous vous
retrouvez du côté de marchiani
d'accord vous préfère rouler toujours
être réincarné en france hollande s'il
faut choisir oui sinon chef gérant cette
question parce que tout bon personne on
veut surtout beaucoup pour la trouille
comme ça à [ __ ] je me dis ah mais
pourquoi être réincarné c'est surtout
salle où les la vie alors est ce que
vous auriez plus de dix ans vous
n'auriez plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles ou
à vue puis de l'absurde et jeunes un nom
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles
pour leur piquer leur sac à main oui
elles sortent de la poste etc hors
pensions 1 ou un vieux qui se tape des
jeunes le vieux qui le vieux qui stoppe
des jeunes avant d'accord et je suis
vieux déjà riche de france
vous savez que c'est agréable alors le
mot le plus con pour vous en amour c'est
merci encore oui-oui ou combien du genou
merci merci merci merci mot stupide
un amour j'entends bien est-ce que vous
préféreriez être coincés dans un
ascenseur avec bernard henri lévy ou
philippe sollers
je me dis alliés bon d'accord vous
voudriez être guillotiné ou pendus
guillotiné disons alors allons-y
guillotiné ça oui c'est à cause du
bouquin parce que vous êtes dedans et
guillotiné
c'est plus rapide sur un s'il faut
choisir je dis pas parce que oui c'est
plus propre d'une certaine manière oui
les pendus encore il va encore d'une
taille respectable même raccourci il ya
des chevaliers sans peine
merci